buddy the elf's dessert spaghetti too  sweet or delicious treat let's find out  first we'll cook up some spaghetti pasta  then we'll top it with chocolate and  caramel maple syrup some M M's and  marshmallows  snow capped frosted toaster pastries  so I'm gonna try this but I thought I  needed a second opinion so I wanted to  bring in my ultimate dessert loving  husband  guilty  hot tart and marshmallow  I could see this being on the menu at  Olive Garden yummy we just smell how  this is this is my taste let me get this  in my hair  it's not bad it's it's good it's not too  sweet I thought it would be too sweet I  just it's a little strange I'm done with  that  one more bite